hey guys my name is Jess McDonald today
this is the third of much and the show
you're watching is gamespot news Ubisoft
have detailed their content and DLC
plans for the first year of the division
and here's everything you'll need to
know about that as for what's free there
will be daily and weekly missions which
offer new tasks and challenges special
events within the game's dark zone and
two free updates to post release the
first is incursions which will be out in
April and is described as a new
challenging endgame activity developed
specifically for squad play should you
be able to take out the waves of enemies
you'll be rewarded with high-level
weapons and equipment the update also
adds loot trading which let's plays of
the same group swap loot collected
during a co-op session the paid
expansions include underground which
comes out in june and lets you explore
the underworld of new york city the
official description reads players will
chase deadly enemies with up to three
other agents through an endless maze of
tunnels and subways coming this summer
is survival where you'll need to not die
for as long as you can by gathering
supplies in a hostile environment and
finally in winter Last Stand will come
out which features a quote new threat
that you'll need to defend against a
teaser video indicates this one could
take place on Liberty Island starting
today you can preload the division on PC
and Xbox one although ps4 users will
have to wait until much sex you can
check out file sizes and the exact time
they're switching on the servers on
gamespot Deep Silver have confirmed the
Dead Island definitive edition is on its
way to ps4 and Xbox one come May 31 the
developer are promising that the $40
re-release of dead island and dead
island riptide will feature higher
quality textures a photo realistic
lighting system physically based shading
image quality enhancements through
anti-aliasing improved game models and
geometry assets hva Oh among other
motion blur effect
and updates to the game to my the ps4
version will also feature remote play
and share play while all versions will
have four player online co-op deep
silver also confirmed that the power
first power up mod will be available in
both games the pack also includes a
brand new standalone 16-bit game called
retro revenge which features melee based
combat leader boards as well as power up
super attacks and a combo system last
month if software revealed the box art
for doom and to put it simply you guys
didn't love it it won't be changing but
it is getting a reverse please the dev
have launched a poll asking fans to vote
on an alternative cover and your choices
include a minimalistic super glue me
demon beasty or be classic doom one
killing literally all the things in a
world where everything is red the pool
will be open for the next four days on
the official doom Twitter account so it
would take your time if it's a tough
decision three launches in May for xbox
one ps4 and PC I'm gonna down in that
comment section which doom cover is your
favorite and we shot ahead to gamespot
or we've gotten use on brand new mirrors
edge videos and a real estate for no
man's sky that is everything I have for
you today with do be sure to join me
same time tomorrow for the top five
stories of the entire week I will catch
you then